رغم الانتعاظ الصينيه تواصل الدول الغربيه
زيارات دبلوماسيه والسياسيه الى تايوان
اخر هذه الزيارات كانت من وفد ليتواني
والماني للجزيره وخرج بعدها نواب
ليتوانيونا لياكد تعرض بلادهم والمستحملين
فيها لكل محاولات كسر الاراده من جانب
بكين وتحديهم لكل هذا
الذي تتعرض له من بكين ممثل للتهديد الذي
تتعرض له بلادهم من روسيا وصفين الاثنتين
روسيا والصين بالجار المستبد ليتوانيا
بعد ان سمحت بفتح مكتب تمثيلي تايوان على
اراضيها تحت اسم تايوان بدلا من تايبي
الصينيه وهو مصطلح تستخدمه دول اخرى لتجنب
غضب بكينا
زياده فتايوان تعول على الدعم الليتواني
وطبعا الالماني للتص لتهديدات تين
انجلش قديمه
ديمقراطيه والحريه اعتبارا من العام
المقبل سيتم تمديد الخدمه العسكريه
الالزاميه لتايوان الى عام واحد لتعزيز
قدرتنا الدفاعيه واظهار عزمنا على الدفاع
عن وطننا وحمايه الديمقراطيه نحن نتطلع
الى تايوان والمانيا والشركاء
الديمقراطيين الاخرين معا للحفاظ على
النظام الاقليمي والازدهار
كل هذه المنشدات تاتي بينما سيكون التعويل
الاول والاكثر اهميه لتايوان هو على
الولايات المتحده بطبيعه الحال خاصه ان
كان هناك اعتداء عسكري صينيه
في هذا الاطار لمركز الدراسات
الاستراتيجيه والدوليه سي اس اي اس نفذ
محاكتا لغزو صيني لتايوان في 20 26 تشارك
فيها جيوش الصين واليابان وتايوان وامريكا
وكانت النتيجه
لكنها ستترك الجيش الامريكي المنتصر في
حاله شلل تماما كحاله القوه الصينيه
المهزومه خلص التقرير الى انه مع نهايه
الحرب ستغرق على الاقل حاملات طائرات
امريكيتان في قاع المحيط الهادئ وستكون
البحريه الصينيه الحديثه وهي الاكبر في
العالم في حاله من الفوضى ويرصد التقرير
مقتل حوالي ثلاثه الاف ومئتين جندي امريكي
في ثلاثه اسابيع من القتال اي ما يقرب من
نصف ما خسرته الولايات المتحده في عقدين
من القتال في العراق وافغانستان
هي الاخرى 10,000 جندي وسيقع عشرات الالاف
من الجنود في الاسر
لكن الجانب الايجابي في الموضوع عن
الخبراء الذين اعتمد التقرير على اراءهم
استبعد غزوه صينيه شاملا للجزيره البالغ
عدد سكانها 24 مليون نسمه
الصريح
ان هذه العمليه ستؤدي على الفور ستؤدي الى
تعطيل الواردات والصادرات التي يعتمد
عليها الاقتصاد الصيني لبقائه وبالتالي قد
تتسبب في انهيار الاقتصاد الصيني في وقت
قصيره
ان الصين التي تعتمد على واردات الغذاء
والوقود لقياده محركها الاقتصادي ليس
لديها مجال كاف للمخاطره او حتى للمنوره
الحرب الشامله مستبعده والضغوط الاقتصاديه
الصينيه هي الاقرب الغاز الصيني لتايوان
قد يسقط الجزيره بالكامل في غضون ثلاثه
اشهر او اقل اذا لم تتدخل امريكا
فان الغزوه الصيني لن ينجح
وبلسمنه سيكون باهظا على الجميع
[موسيقى]